this is a story about faking it till you
make it you know so you got to fake it
till you make it you got to fake it till
you make it sometimes it's a good idea
sometimes that's not a bad idea but
basically this store this story has
everything to do with faking it till you
make it and manifestations this is a
story about drake so drake was gifted a
rolls royce he used to rent for 5k a
month to keep up appearances this is a
complex story so
drake who by the way is now 35 years old
that's crazy drake is 35 years old
you know what drake is worth
150 million 150 million
but back in the day 2007
he was uh 21 years old young buck he did
his uh degrassi high stuff probably had
a couple bucks to his name but he
certainly wasn't rolling in the deep in
the green right adel right like dell
reference he didn't have a lot of loot
uh he was 21 years old back in 2007 and
he basically said i had to fake it till
i make it so what he said is and this is
a word that i want to use more often he
said i had to
i had to finesse
this rolls royce phantom rental to
convince people that we were destined to
make it he says i used to scrape
together 5k a month to keep up
appearances basically fake it to your
making he had no money he was dropping
5k a month 60 grand a year to roll
around in a rolls royce phantom so he
basically talked about he was
manifesting you know i'm gonna be a
freaking
rap star this is interesting dude
because this kind of goes against your
i'm going to go somewhere with this i'm
going to go somewhere with this hey i'm
curious so now basically fast forward 35
years old worth 150 million his friend
now 20 21 here we go and his friend is
called future the prince
and he basically says he tracked down
the exact car
that he used to basically stress over
making 5k a month and and um
this guy bought the car
and gifted it to him
and he basically says drake says it's
mine now
manifestation complete
full circle right
so this is 14 years later so it
basically says look i get it i don't
necessarily condone spending money that
you don't really have on material things
for sure in this case
but this was what he calls extreme
manifesting all right
so manifesting going all in i'm burning
the ships
okay i'm doing all in so let me tell you
something i don't have a crazy i was
rocking a a um
a rolls-royce phantom for five grand a
month but looking back i said okay what
can i take from this story that i was
willing to do to bet on myself to keep
up appearances and i said you know what
when i was broke 27 years old just
starting downtown financial career i
needed a nice suit
and i invested in a nice suit probably
spent a thousand bucks on a suit that i
was like i'm freaking sleeping in this
suit if i need to okay but i wore it to
every single meeting every business
conference like i would change maybe
shirts but i would rock this dope navy
blue suit constantly do you still have
it no no
it's it's
that's 15 years later
ironically
it was a donald trump suit
oh how's the turn taking how things have
changed
this is when donald trump the
businessman before the president
ironically it was a trump suit a djt
donald trump suit pinstripe i thought i
was the coolest guy around but basically
i invested myself
i bought a donald trump thousand dollar
suit and i said yo i'm gonna
i'm gonna make it in the business world
i'm so i'm gonna figure this thing out
and if i
and if not i'm gonna look good while
doing it yeah so that was my rolls-royce
phantom i could not afford a thousand
bucks at that point in my life yeah on a
suit but i said this is something that
i'm gonna wear to every single business
meeting that i'm gonna rock that that is
gonna make me feel good and make me look
good you know yeah you know they say you
know you look good you feel good you
feel good you perform good yeah boom
and it worked out well for me so i'm not
saying that i'm condoning these types of
things
but
let's say i would have spent that money
on a watch that watch really wouldn't
have done nobody's going to do business
because i got a cool watch
so a lot of people out there will maybe
um spend that money on a car
yeah to keep up appearances
but drake is this was called extreme
manifesting you ever fake it till you
make it
everyone ever done anything that you
would fake it do you make it no i
haven't but this reminds me of a little
story from a little country we talked
about a few weeks ago papua new guinea
where they were like let's fake it till
we make it boys
buy those maseratis yes and we shat on
them pretty hard pretty hard so
where it's like where do you draw the
line yeah drake kind of just got lucky
you you could say well okay
here's how i would i would have turned
this
this extreme manifesting drake has
basically said i'm going all in yeah pop
a new game on this round
we're going all in on this country thing
no and we're going to difference
maseratis to fake it till we make that
was that we were in debt
but
that's a poor country they were doing
that drake was a their man they were
doing that to impress people so was
drake he just said so
but the difference was extreme
manifesting he said i'm gonna freak
drake is a talented dude he knew that he
had talent probably nothing talented
about papua new guinea you don't know
that no no no no papa new beginning
anyway look
this is drake's like did it work out
well for drake you can't be an
and say not that you're being an
you can't say i would never it clearly
worked out well for you yeah but i think
that's so such a scary thing to put into
the minds of young impressionable kids
that are like oh i want to be like drake
and it worked for drake man i gotta do
the same thing i gotta invest in this
dumb ass purchase
fake it till i make it and then next
thing you know you're 29 and you're
still like hey i'm gonna be the next new
thing y'all better watch out no and
you're still waiting and because i have
a bunch of friends and i'm like
you still think huh okay buddy well at
one point i think it's like i don't
believe in the whole like you can do
whatever you want to do
no i think it's like dude at one point
you're just not good you're just not
good
you have to find your thing and although
you want this to be your thing
dude i would give anything to play for
chelsea yeah that's not going to happen
it's not going to happen yeah so maybe i
should just move on to something i'm
actually good at
well drake was good at wrapping i think
that was the thing sure exactly so it
worked out for goodreads because he's
good at it yes but people are like if
you do it no your limits is what you're
saying no your limits bro you're living
if it's been in your years and you've
seen no change in your damn soundcloud
well that's what i respect about lil
dicky speaking of rappers is he's
basically saying i'm gonna be the
anti-rapper i'm gonna save that money
okay i'm not going to pretend to be
some ultra you know exactly rocking
look people see past
the the rappers making it rain spending
money they get it bro like yeah exactly
i'm kind of an idiot that's why lil
dicky made it because he does have that
because he's real he's authentic he's
real he's off fiscal conservative save
that money and it's uh are we gonna say
that much exactly no and that's a whole
music thing that i can get into where
it's like be genuine okay and then
people will like that but if you're
trying to mimic and copycat so the
future so there is a fine line is what
you're saying between faking it till you
make it yeah and extreme manifestation
yes and understand the difference 100
and understand where you're at on the
uh the linear equation of i'm just
faking it papua new guinea style yeah or
i'm extremely
manifesting this drake because i think
and where you're at on that yeah also
dude drake also had you know his foot in
the door he was onto grassy he had
connections so like he could kind of
afford to fake it till he made it
because what he did this during the
grassy days or prior this is a 2007. i
think his first big hit was
maybe in 2010
he's on the network he's got you know i
can but if you're some dude from broward
not saying that you can't make it but
it's like be careful bro
because you could end up you could end
up failing miserably and being in debt
and that's not a good look okay well i
think we had a good little banter i
think we had a little disagreement there
i think that not you know not everything
is as easily
defined as yeah as you know faking it to
you make it extreme manifestation
understand the difference for me i
bought a nice suit it was an investment
i faked it till i made it until i
started actually doing business but
if i would invest in that into a car
maybe that wouldn't have been the best
approach so understand what you're doing
exactly what you said no one would have
given a if you had a nice watch
nobody no one would have given a
even a nice car no people give a
hey this guy looks good this guy looks
good fake it till you make it so
understand there's
maybe when you fake it till you make it
there's different
ways to approach that yeah okay
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken